now this movement of self-consciousness
in relation to another
self-consciousness has in this way been
represented as the action of one
self-consciousness but this action of
the one has itself the double
significance of being both its own
action and the action of the other as
well for the other is equally
independent and self-contained and there
is nothing in it of which it is not
itself the origin the first does not
have the object before it merely as it
exists primarily for desire but as
something that has an independent
existence of its own which therefore it
cannot utilize for its own purposes if
that object is not of its own accord do
what the first does to it thus the
movement is simply the double movement
of the two self consciousnesses each
sees the other do the same as it does
each does itself what it demands of the
other and therefore also does what it
does only insofar as the other does the
same action by one side only would be
useless because what is to happen can
only be brought about by both
in paragraph 182 we now have to self
consciousnesses which are confronting
each other as such they are confronting
each other in a kind of reciprocity or
mirroring that has reached the stage
where it's no longer one confronting an
ambiguous other although ambiguity is
we're gonna see still enters into this
this doubling effect that's taking place
but now it's grasping that the other
self-consciousness really is as we say
an independent self-contained thing like
itself and you know in the past
paragraphs at the from the beginning of
this portion of the section on we've had
this this you know what Hegel called an
ambiguous supersession you know an
ambiguous relation to the other and the
term that was used there was Dhokla
zenok right zyne means something like
sense or meaning significance here we
have something that that's being called
a doubled meaning as well there it's
doubled
Bedoya tone the significance of it the
you might say even the the rendering the
translation of it if we want to play a
little fast and loose with translation
ourselves there and what's really
important in this in this passage is
that now self-consciousness has worked
its way through those ambiguities and
it's arrived at a place where we're
gonna see greater ambiguities arising or
greater doublings horizon so he says
this movement of self-consciousness in
relation to another self-consciousness
has been in this way represented as the
action of one self-consciousness so this
is the self this is the other right and
then it realizes oh hey I'm over there
it's the same as me that means that I
have to worry about in assuming the
importance that I think that I have
better superseded better off you know
okay boom it in the however we want to
translate all pave on transcend it
subordinated would be another way that
we could think about it this was
removing to the master-slave dialectic
proper and then in case I have to
transcend it and in doing so that I
realized that I'm also because it
contains myself transcending myself now
it's no longer than he says but this
action of the one Kazakhs has itself the
double significance of being both its
own action in the action of the other as
well so when I when I what is the action
that we're talking about here it's the
way in which we're taking a perspective
on our relation to the other person and
on the other person to us this could
take place in multiplicity of modes it
could be action directly where I is
we're going to see a little bit later
attack them or it could be action in the
sense of a passion that sounds a little
bit paradoxical I know where I feel
something towards them like anxiety for
example it could be action in other
senses as well but in any case we might
think of it as taking a stance towards
the other now what when Hegel says is
that what what's going on here is much
more complicated if I'm the eye over
here I act towards the other but the
other act towards me at the same time
and in the same way that my action is
duplicated as a matter of fact I might
not even be the first person to act
perhaps this one acts first and I'm the
one who's mirroring and I didn't even
realize that I was doing that until I
engaged in the action itself I thought I
was the one who is doing things first
and then I realized a little
introspection no they did it first
usually this works out that way when
we're trying to accuse somebody of doing
something wrong right you you
transgressed first but he says it's the
double significance of being both its
only action in the action of the other
as well the other is equally independent
and self-contained each
self-consciousness is something
at least at this point appears to exist
on its own but yet they're also
connected with each other so the first
does not have the object before it
merely as it exists primarily for desire
both self-consciousness is are in fact
desire but their relation to each other
isn't one that can be totally subsumed
within the realm of desire precisely
because what desire does we saw this
before in earlier sections of
self-consciousness is takes its object
and consumes it there's a dialectic of
desire that leads to a replication of
desire right as the desired object is
taken in and thereby brought to nothing
made part of the ego the self the self
consciousness the person that's not
quite possible in terms of this kind of
object self-consciousness another
self-consciousness so he says it's
something that has independent existence
of its own which therefore it cannot
utilize for its own purposes if that
object is not of its own accord do what
the first does to it so what we have
going on here is I'm going to put this
in terms of I and an other I act right I
see that same action being replicated by
the other it could be an act like gazing
it could be an act like smiling it could
be all sorts of things and even within
my act
I can't act unless the other is in some
way contributing by the reaction to my
very action this larger action here what
we might say the explicit action is
indeed the same thing as this and
likewise we can say this is the same as
that shouldn't be like that should be
like this instead very this is in on a
macro level but this is fold it into
this
action and vice-versa so we've got a
very complex structure being outlined
here he says the movement is simply the
double movement of the two self
consciousnesses each sees the other do
the same as it does now I've only drawn
these you know seeing doing and demands
on one side you could you know fill them
in on the other side but then our
diagram would get much too complicated
so I'm going to keep it nice and simple
each sees the other doing what it's
doing right so it's not just that I do
something and somebody else
imitates or replicates what I'm doing in
relation to me it's also that I see that
happening I witness it I perhaps don't
even see it necessarily in a ocular
sense but I imagine that it's going on
as well that's another possibility too
in any case there's some sort of
perception that the other is engaged in
the same sort of activity as I myself am
what happens after that
says each does itself what it demands on
the other so I demand some sort of
action from the other look at me look at
me I'm here listen to me I wanna have
something to say in demanding that of
the other I'm expecting some sort of
action from them and I have to also you
know kind of reciprocity do that very
action if I'm going to tell you look at
me because I'm a person I have to treat
you as a person already it doesn't make
any sense for me to tell the camera hey
look at me right because the camera does
what it does it's just a mechanism the
camera can't give me the same sort you
might say interaction or validation or
reciprocity as another person does and
the only reason why as I'm talking here
in a nearly empty room to a camera that
I can I can you know sort of imagine
that I'm doing that
made it in my gestures is because I'm
imagining another self-consciousness on
the other side of their camera because I
know that this is being used you know
for for YouTube in this case right
we're being preserved for posterity if
I'm sitting you know recording something
down the line if it was totally
disconnected if it was just a camera and
you know pure mechanism
I wouldn't be able to have quite the
same comportment towards it would I have
to assume that there's another being on
the other side of it so he says
therefore each does what it does only
insofar as the other does the same now
does this mean of course that if I
scratch my head the other scratching his
head you're witnessing me scratching my
head no it's not about trivial gestures
it's about the things that are deciding
what a person actually is what we might
call gestures or actions that have some
sort of moral or metaphysical depth to
them understanding those terms in very
broad senses so he says action by one
side what would only would be useless
because what is to happen can only be
brought about by both this is a good
place to pause and think about the range
of things that are really only possible
as such when they are reciprocal now
they can happen in somewhat degenerate
or incomplete ways when one person does
it think about for example unrequited
love right we say unrequited when there
is an action of loving on one side and
this action could be the feeling of love
it could be actions of love choices all
sorts of things that get establishing
some common bough bond wishing well to
the other there's lots of definitions of
love but then it doesn't happen in
return
there is a kindness there's a sense in
which the one is you know blocked it's
not giving of itself the way that the
other one is it's a non reciprocal
action
are there other actions where this
reciprocity is going to be inherent to
the nature of it and we might think at
least for those of us who
who are prone to bad temper about the
effect of getting angry at a person of
them getting angry on us in return for
getting angry at us and then we argue
about who got angry first and on and on
and on that would be a perfect example
of the sort of thing that Eagle is
describing here this is probably
something I need to write down after I
get finished with this because I do so
much work on on anger this actually fits
it quite well in any case what he what
he's talking about here is the moment
where self-consciousness has become
aware of each other
he has existing in relation to each
other in this reciprocity as independent
self-contained existences that now we're
facing off
thus the action has a double
significance not only because it is
directed against itself as well as
against the other but also because it is
indivisibly the action of one as well as
of the other
paragraph 183 is very short and actually
doesn't require too much commentary it's
it's a remark that is in a sense
completing what was going on in
paragraph one eighty eighty two and is
going to look ahead to what's going on
in a much longer 184 so Hegel talks
about again double significance here in
this case it's the same thing that we're
calling ambiguity a little bit earlier
so it's a doubles inning all right it's
ambiguous it can be interpreted in two
ways
and he says the action has a double
significance it has this ambiguity for
two reasons
so the first ambiguity or the first
dimension of that ambiguity was that the
action is not only directed against the
other but is thereby that's how I've
depicted this directed against the self
that is an engaging in the action and
why would this be the case while the
other is an other self it is a
self-consciousness it has the same sort
of structure as I do and here we're
getting to something really important
the the real ambiguity lies and the fact
is he says that when we read the passage
that such it is indivisibly the action
of one as well as on the other so
without ceasing to be my action it is
also the action of the other now we can
understand this in in several different
ways
we can understand this as the other is
somehow in some way you know implicitly
or covertly contributing to my action or
guiding it so that it doesn't just get
directed against themselves but also
against myself or perhaps you know that
it they direct it so that it actually
does go against themselves rather than
just against myself there's other
possibilities as well and we're going to
see these possibilities get played out
in in the future para so we have two
different double significance is going
on here there's a double significance
that the
action is essentially not split but but
it has two different aspects its its
direct against the other but also
against myself at the same time and the
other is engaging in the same kind of
action or the other is provoking that
kind of action or however else what
other mode we want to see the other
taking you might say some ownership over
that action
in this movement we see repeated the
process which presented itself as the
play of forces but repeated now in
consciousness what in that process was
for us is true here of the extremes
themselves the middle term is
self-consciousness which splits into the
extremes and each extreme is this
exchanging of its own determinate 'no
solute transition into the opposite
although as consciousness it does indeed
come out of itself yet though out of
itself it is at the same time kept back
within itself it is for itself and the
self outside it is for it it is aware
that it at once is and is not another
consciousness and equally that this
other is for itself only when it
supersedes itself as being for itself
and it is for itself only in the being
for self of the other each is for the
other the middle term through which each
mediates itself with itself and unites
with itself and each is for itself and
for the other and immediate being on its
own account which at the same time it is
such only through this mediation they
recognize themselves as mutually
recognizing one another
paragraph 184 is continuing to explore
what we might call the contours or the
structure of the reciprocal relation
with the other self-consciousness
interestingly you want to keep in mind
too while we're exploring what that is
for us the other self consciousness is
doing exactly the same thing in return
by virtue of the fact that they are
another self-consciousness and that's
going to come out a bit more in this
section in this paragraph than it did in
the previous paragraph so Hegel starts
out by saying that there's an
interesting analogy here a sort of
mirroring of structure we saw earlier
with the play of forces in force in the
understanding you know forces would
would you know solicit each other and
the one who's who's you know soliciting
is being solicited into solicited with
various complex interplay as it turns
out and I didn't play not only about
agency about activity and and you know
soliciting but also about you know being
in itself and forts of all these other
other determinations so I think it was
saying that there's an analogy or a
similarity of structure that there's an
analog here to self-consciousness in its
doubled form and it's necessarily
doubled form by the way like we said
before you do not have a
self-consciousness that is not already
connected with another
self-consciousness it just doesn't work
that way for self-consciousness so then
he's going to go on and he's gonna say
self-consciousness itself is the middle
term and we're getting to the language
that he likes to employ about syllogisms
right you know he galleon syllogisms are
not the same thing as Aristotelian
syllogisms whatever you may think you
know about Aristotelian syllogisms which
are actually scholastic ones Aristotle
and a much broader way of talking about
it be that as it may
what's important here is that
self-consciousness itself becomes a
middle or mediating term and we're going
to see how that plays it
self out when it splits itself as he
says into the two selves that's the two
consciousnesses the reason why I put a
dividing line here or something almost
like a division sign instead of just you
know the dash is because he starts
playing back and forth a bit with with
these terms and and you know it's a
lexical way of symbolizing something
that's going on in this paragraph and
also through the rest of it which is
that consciousness is trying to figure
out what the hell it is and what that
self is and the self is at the same time
bound up with the consciousness of the
other this is almost starting to sound a
little bit like Lacan and if that's the
case that's because Lacan is actually
drawing quite a bit on what's in Hegel
at this point let's not get too deep
into you know interpretation though
let's let's stick with the text so he
says the middle term is
self-consciousness or listen to the
extremes and each extreme is this
exchanging of its own determinate Ness
and an absolute transition into the
opposite so the same thing is happening
on both sides of this this splitting
this doubling there's a determinate Ness
that is taking place and also a movement
towards motivated by desire as we've
seen towards the other its exchanging
its own determinate Ness and an absolute
transition into the opposite what's the
opposite you know being something other
than it would has been determined to be
so he says although his consciousness it
does indeed come out of itself yeah
though out of itself it is at the same
time kept back within its own okay that
happened we saw with the interplay of
forces right a force that comes out of
itself into the phenomena that it's
trying to express that it is acting upon
that is acting through it comes out of
itself it comes out of the sort of inner
resources and yet at the same time it's
kept back within itself something of
that otherwise it would not remain
course it would just be the individual
instances that we see right so he goes
on when he says this is happening for
self consciousness it is for itself it
has this relationship of being able to
take a stance upon itself that's what
makes it self consciousness right it has
to be for itself where it's not self
consciousness and that happens on both
sides both of them are for themselves
and then he says and the self outside of
it is for it what is the self outside of
it well here's where it gets interesting
we could say two different things the
self outside of it is a sort of
externalization of itself which is also
for it when I go through these moments
where I feel that I am NOT just say my
costume and I realized it yet at the
same time I am my costume this is
starting to sell more surgery doesn't it
that would be what Hegel is describing
there's another self outside of it as
well though right the self of the other
the self of the other self consciousness
and that is for it as well so each is
not only for itself is also for another
and it is equally for another as it is
for itself you don't get here's it
here's how Hegel might be saying this at
this point you don't get to define
precisely what you are only in your own
terms
you're doing it in part through the
mediation of the other so he says it is
a we're at once that it is and it is not
another consciousness I I am this but I
am also this over here even though I
don't feel from that person's
perspective or see the world from their
perspective what happens though when I
am listening to another story and I may
what it is to see the world through
their eyes or to feel as they do how am
I able to do that at all if I can't in a
certain sense beware the other is one of
the things where it's involving what you
know Augustine for example said look you
know when it comes to certain things we
can't enjoy the same good if I put my
hand on a beautiful body you can't put
your hand there until I move it as well
but when it comes to thought knowledge
wisdom if I understand the Pythagorean
theorem which by the way is you know the
go-to for all sorts of you know examples
like this but it has a certain beauty to
it right a certain attractiveness to it
a certain intelligibility if I
understand it and then I convey that
understanding to you if I lost anything
in the process if I taken away some of
my you know storehouse of that and given
it to you know you now have the same
thing and it becomes yours just as much
as mine and it's because it's really
neither one of us that owns it it is
something that transcends both of us in
that way and when it comes to self
consciousness and its relation to the
other it works that way as well so he's
saying that this in at once is and is
not another consciousness equally this
other is for itself only when it
supersedes itself as being for itself
and it is for itself only in the being
for self of the other now that's a
complex thing that he just said I've
actually got it drawn here so that when
a self consciousness technically should
be over there on the other side right
but when a self consciousness supersedes
its own being for self it overcomes that
it transcends it it incorporates it and
it now grasps its being for the other as
the other is for itself let me read this
passage one more time it is for itself
only in the beating for self
the other it grasps itself no longer
from its own perspective but from the
perspective of the other but notice here
not simply as an object for the other
but as the other is grasping its own
self what's the difference here
something very important is going on
when we when we think about this when I
can see myself not only as an object in
the other's eyes but as another self the
way that the other understands what it
means to be a self what it means to be a
conscious human being I gain a different
perspective upon myself don't I that
might be something negative but it might
also be something very positive
think about the encounters where really
have a certain self understanding so
there's a there's a reflexive 'ti there
I am just this guy who does this sort of
thing and then we see ourselves from the
perspective of the other who's not just
looking at us as an object say something
to exploit something to make do
something but rather in terms of their
own self relation in terms of how they
understand what it means to be a person
to be a human being and let's say they
have a more expansive concept of that
that that unlocks human potential or
even recognizes human potential more my
supersession of myself in that case my
own perspective means moving to a better
perspective it could also be a worse
perspective right if I have a rich you
know inner reflexive life and then I'm
forced into the confines of a
bureaucratic mentality that barely
understands itself let alone what it is
to be another human being that could be
a real loss as well but this is inherent
in the nature of self-consciousness as
a dynamic hey no thanks so he says
here's where we come back to the
self-consciousness is the middle term
each is for the other that middle term
each of them is self-consciousness the
mediating term for the other
self-consciousness whether you realize
it or not whether you're in the higher
or lower spot on the power dynamic
whether you came before or came after
you are a mediating term for another
self-consciousness this doesn't mean
that it's necessarily going to be all
great there's many ways of mediating
that aren't so great it's a sea of the
master-slave dialectic so he goes on and
he says through which each mediates
itself with itself and unites with
itself and each is for itself and for
the other an immediate being on its own
account which at the same time is such
only through this mediation where Hegel
is going to conclude with this is saying
we might want to be catchy ki he
recognizes that recognition is mutual
recognition that this process of honor
Kenan you know recognizing the the other
as as a person is self recognition
that's part of the mutual and also Gagan
you know there's this opposition
function going on so you might say like
I put here recognition is mutual
recognition of recognizing of
recognizing that the other is engaged in
the process of recognition and expecting
or demanding the same thing from us we
are all mediating terms for each other
is what Hegel has expressed here
you